what's up everybody welcome back to
first AK here in Puerto Rico the final
Tenkaichi amount were crawling through
this bracket we've had our first four
matches and we're gonna jump through
some more we have some good ones coming
up to the stage of course I see both of
them already seated ready to jump into
our losers bracket matches and hopefully
you guys at home have been enjoying it
as well we had to double shoot to a
break but we made it back nice and quick
these breaks are nice and sure I think
they're like three minutes longer some
like that they're only three minutes and
we got the return of the snack
yes the return of the snack looking nice
and ready up stage right there against
subatomic savers who got sent down to
loser bracket just a minute ago with
some drops a little you know series of
unfortunate events that dropped him down
here so he's gonna be playing up against
Nakia who had that win over to kill sage
earlier he went home with 7th place and
I'm excited to see it all right west
coast East Coast battle the coach right
now let's go yeah it's gonna be a quick
button truck and then we'll get into the
set between these two has been playing
really strong too
yeah he's so good the funny thing about
sub is like you know if you don't tune
into wins and I fights and you might say
wins and I fights never heard of it well
you can find Dragonball there each and
every week on twitch.tv slash Kevin
underscore hall with all these lovely
players in the top eight many of them
attend to each and every week anyway if
you don't watch that you might not see a
subatomic savers too much he only shows
up like you know - I think maybe like a
few locals a year there are a few of the
big events a year and this is one of the
ones he's travelling out to obviously
top eight here Tom made a combo breaker
he's been traveling a little bit more
having a lot more success in this game
but also if we're gonna talk about your
coasts we're gonna talk about the East
Coast here - you might be familiar and
if you're not with NLB see ya you know
team spooky and what they're doing there
all the time and you might see neck
y'all play a lot you wander this week I
was a good top a good top eight in top
three they are talking about childís
vegeto and they're a big fan of that guy
yeah it's a solid super solid it cracks
me up every time so we get to see
another vegeto player here it's clever
one of the East Coast finest transplant
from up in the northwest who he loves
you know every time I hear in part about
New York he's like this place is great
it's OD that's all he ever says if
that's how it is I can hear that it's
gonna haunt me yeah that's his voice oh
ok skipping the intros going right into
it now if y'all's kid buu looking like a
grape comma same team purple a call off
the jump age
the unfortunate thing is that not kill
you know round start come back and then
he came up all that space and stuff did
a great job of chasing it taking
advantage and now he's got the corner
position already early sparking there to
get out of that situation
super dashing in man here are the hit
against this vegeto that's coming out
with yeah very patient play from stuff
out of the corner
gumball misses I like a change in the
mystic ball just try and cover himself
in case he gets press the button there
yeah I like to reflect you I mean he
knew he was gonna have the stagger to
get an assist back corners we saw and
the GAR cancel work hit on the go tank
yeah that is huge
why a snap gonna bring himself Paul
character there that was crazy yeah
those are three really really clutch
blocks that worked out back-to-back his
assists gets nice and look at how
patient subatomic saver is right waiting
for his moment yeah I gonna get a mix-up
off of this air dash over but too small
couldn't get anything really that big
wrap legs
Betty lost the corner again on that
guard canceled
one of the things that I really love
about high-level Dragon Ball 2 is you
see this patient and both players
respecting both @tp yeah that's CP right
there as soon as sub was like all right
maybe it's safe to start some offense
again if he comes out and it's good to
condition people to make you nothing and
we get to hit with that low there yeah a
bit like that not leveled up and try to
leg loop on go tanks it's one of those
ones who always practice this is like
loops on all different size characters
in this game how unfortunate to H gonna
get him
the extension off the beam five bars
going right into the level one here into
the cell level three yeah a lot of
damage on that and you know they both
spent sparking so far no characters died
but now is where it gets rough level one
out level three back to the corner to
that's gonna be a side switch which is a
big deal and you give her the okie and
the damage zone is crazy because it's
not leveled up use that reflex to get
out of the situation gets them in the
air screws are covering down the rolling
crushing beautiful dog Jill did a little
micro - out of the corner got under for
that I'll love it I was really really
well done jumping back at the beginning
here it's nice and slow and yeah that
beam is excellent if you get above it
you can't super dance to punish it so
you can't be too crazy with it but it
was a really really good option in
neutral for naki I'll bringing kid food
back in in yeah he just ran up in 2h and
I think it was a syrup of a mystic ball
look like or something yeah going right
into the final kamehameha here a lot of
damage one more mix up for the kill
does that the assist I like that you
tried to cover the air there with that
sword
man their friends four days each the tag
oh the jabs right into the dragon rush
it's gonna be a dead kid boo
yeah no meter necessary it's a really
big you know we got tied up here this is
exactly I think what we expect it
probably Bolton's fence marking early
the match is close and it's like a one
hit master such an important moment for
both players manage my into the donut
but yeah super - dude just one for a
joyride bringing go tanks 6m connects
and more than enough meter here
Knockhill we'll see how he chooses to
extend he was actually playing for a
while we got the gank you dumb mother as
you would say look at those teeth molars
water's nice he didn't even go for the
easy combo got the dragon rush after
that's really good a lot of people just
raw I like take the raw level one after
if they don't want to try it or anything
but not feel save the meter and that
meter could go a long way so solo vegeto
now where you want to be I think
probably on this team I think the
character maybe you want last the leaf
okay I like I like the patients care
from both gets them with a diagonal
beatdown
try to wake up - well I just the up back
for Nakia worked out gonna be the drop
one now can all taking game one here
against subatomic sabers one point for
the East Coast
very well played I like that a lot from
Knockhill I think it did a good job of
like really surviving in those corner
scenarios where vegeta thrives and sub
as the player who's very patient right
he doesn't over commit when you're on
defense so for that reason I think
Knockhill just took that advantage to be
like okay you're not gonna press too
hard we run in the corners gonna jump
out and I think that that's where this
part decision taking that energy from
winning Game one going right into the
drop elbow miss homo Auto combo reset
but wasn't ready for it to hit and
tagout in to go things that could been
great big to if you would have liked
yeah you might as well snap you can't
get really get too much beside that
there and sliding off now it's not gonna
take you very far
beyblade hello great defense here
tonight this is what I mean about the
corner pressure notice house up had the
corner but he backed off and he didn't
overcome it I think that knock Hill has
been noticing that and you know that
lack of commitments us any kind of
offenses let him just get out of the
corner no you're right goes back off a
lot yeah clean even though the assist
was out he wasn't scared he knew that
once the heat up it was going to go away
mystic ball that heavy snap okay yeah
we're gonna see a snap bringing vegeto
just goes low yeah that was good reflex
oh and the 2h calling him out there on
being above them yeah sword size flaw
level three it's great if your stuff and
I think you got to turn on the offense
here he's down a sparking so a kill
would be great well that was a sparking
bait right there that 5l in the tag
that's to beat uh sparking on a block
son if you've blocked the vegeto 5l we
don't normally see early parkings out of
naki although so
yeah I think if you think it's gonna
save a character it's very good and you
know despite that sparking bait not
working out so I'm still got the kill
gonna take the level up yeah you have to
preemptively expect that to punish it
you get like run up and do it to em or
jump up superdad something we got hit by
the 6h he's like always prepared for the
combo I feel like he's always got a plan
spark managed to secure the hint here
with go on he is leveled up to level 1
yeah put them low four bars there yeah a
lot of damage that's like the first
mix-up I ever saw Knockhill dude like it
was like NCR 2018 he did that to
somebody with like Goku's level 3 we're
bringing it back that is a real real
classic mix look that's been to two
characters apiece
he'll medium just feel so good yes the
help in is here - back over all right
lean elbow drop into the corner and I
love that - from sub knowing that
there's gonna be an air dives over from
Knockhill wow klip them bring him back
down to the ground
the combo though the light beat it hits
another combo to get started for him oh
we dropped the super when he landed he
tried it I thought he was gonna do the
ghost kamikaze ride unfortunate thing
right she's got the issue but it's the
air to air there wow he's light as air
action I thought he had already used it
but he's thought the double jump
available 1 bar kill there's the ghost
kamikaze super ghost kamikaze attack I
logo tanks the arrow go thinks is a good
time for me I love this character he's
great
you know as much as I like this
character I'm glad not everyone has this
character on their team that's true yeah
yeah we are in the age of GT Goku so
yeah I don't know if you could have got
a combo of that it float that sub-users
is really useful to him like pilot
around in neutral with a little bit of
meter I do like his shout cancel
good call bars here going into the ghost
kamikaze again great the events will not
deal I mean you know back when that was
like really popular he was one of the
people that was like hey here's how you
deal with this no we got nothing after
it where was the cobble from some come
back here that is so unfortunate for
subatomic savers now read um combo level
one powered up cuz his homies are gone
man that is rough this is just this is
just like who super dad system using
that anti-air tech there with vegeto got
ride under up and said alright you won't
super - you're afraid of a 2h or
something grab them out of the air very
well done from sub what a piece tossing
to the side just Thompson alright we're
gonna know game 3 here yeah I really
like it this set is been great so far -
really really good and technical players
for sure and you can see the differences
in like their team and what that means
for them yeah we've said a lot of these
to H Snipes
from subatomic savers so far stanchion
off that one thing about playing you
know this team right if you have go
tanks gray combo extensions for vegeto
ya run under again you know very safe
pressure that was a big reflect with
but this is not he's opened up at the
low from Navi oh yeah just Belen went
low and again sob in the corner is gonna
be a level up here so up at the corners
is not pressing a lot and for that
reason you really see a knock he'll take
advantage which run under like we saw
last the 4s yeah oh you got the super -
nothing after runs up to em check he
doesn't have any assists man really
really save stuff from subatomic shout
can soul yeah and look like he was
trying to base something and Knockhill
did go for the spark snaps into the kid
buu sparking is running out auto combo
the reflect miss
super - for the extension this is great
setting up with the ghost pressure off
of this ok good time to tag in there can
you cut it back up and look like he was
almost trying to bait that and get the
2h but nothing after two am okay going
into heavy legs with the teacher dope
who's been gonna lock you down
great times spark for subatomic sabers
yeah I like that counter spark there I
think it's probably time to spend in
here expensive with Goku I leveled up so
legs to a to elbow rebars to going into
that level three let's see it
so we'll see at the mix-up situations
like after our Castle nice Gatling good
punished on that yeah doesn't get a snap
off bill a lot of meter here with the
legs
and as far as it can elbow drop this is
so bad for sub yeah half the block the
gumball mix-up perfect yeah you can tell
that sub was waiting for the frames
right he's like okay I'm gonna let you
block this I'm gonna have plus frames
afterwards knock yo reflect challenge
right away knowing that subatomic savers
just waiting there okay with the jump
medium powers brutal later - clip them
again an elbow drop easy peasy level 1
subs here but still just relentless on
the offense here drop the level 3 and
that'll do it nah kill moving on 2 to 1
over subatomic saver and losers give it
up for subatomic savers - repping out
here for the west coast couple west
coast killer for the bobble there all
the winner side some West Coast prize
for you guys yeah that's cool too
especially the best part is sup loss and
the first thing there's like a smile on
his face it's like a good game game that
happens you know and really well played
especially that last game from Nakia I
think there's like a really strong
recognition of the kind of way that
subatomic saver likes the pressure and
Nakia just had a really good read about
how to stop it he's like all right let
me just wait you're gonna like give me
space on on wakeup I was going to jump
over or skip the corner something like
that it was a really smart play I think
and I feel like it's a big confidence
boost like as soon as he is getting
and hits you just see a totally
different person like he had lost that
second game but just manages to keep
coming and coming back in that third
game yeah yeah I'm really